من عمان لواء فايز الدوير الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي
المعلومات المتوفره عن باخموت ما الصوره
التي ترسمها لما يجري الان في المدينه
يعني لا يزال القتال مستمر في الاجزاء
دعنا نقول ما بعد وسط المدينه باتجاه
الغرب حيث المبنى الاداري
يقع الى الغرب من النهر
وبالتالي لا يزال الحديث مبكر عن السيطره
التامه على المدينه ولكن ما تم الاعلان
عنه له هو نجاح في بعدين البعد المادي اي
حدث هناك اختراق وتم السيطره على ما يطلق
عليه المجمع الاداري او المربع الامني
والبعد الاخر التاثير المعنوي لصالح قوات
فاجنر اي انها تحقق انجازات خاصه
وانها تحاول الاغلاق المقترب الجنوبي
الغربي الذي يتم محاصرته ومحاوله قطع
الطريق من الاتجاه الشمالي ومن اتجاه
الجنوبي وبالتالي هذه خطوه للامام تحسب
لقوات فاجنر ولكنها لا تعني فرض السيطره
وقد يستمر القتال لفتره يصعب تحديدها لان
عوامل
استمرار القتال يعتمد على متغيرات كثيره
اهمها ما هو مخزونات على القوات المتواجده
من المستلزمات العملياتيه او الاداريه وما
امكانيه امدادها اذا لكانت ما زالت
المخزونات جيده امكانيه الامداد قائمه قد
يستمر القتال لفتره قد تطول شيئا ما
وحينما نقول تطول لان نتحدث عن اسابيع عن
اشهر عن ايام لان هنالك معلومات من الجانب
الروسي تتحدث عن ايام وعلى الاكثر اسابيع
انا لا اتوقع ان تطول لاشهر لا يعني
القوات كلا الجانبين تم استنزاف قواته لكن
يبدو ان المقاربه الاوكرانيه بدات تاخذ
بصوره اكثر جديه وقناعه ان استمرار في خوض
معركه باخ مكلف جدا واصبحت التكلفه اكبر
من اهميه الموقع الجغرافي او حتى
الاستراتيجيه او الرمزيه لكن كم ستستمر لا
لا اتفق مع الجانب الروسي ايام قد تكون
لعده اسابيع لنقل ثلاث الى اربعه اسابيع
اذا توفرت عوامل القدره على الصمود للقوات
الاوكرانيه ما لم تحدث هناك تغيرات في
الموقف السياسي يطلب الاقلاع او اذا ما
نجحت القوات الروسيه بقطع الطريق
في هذه في هذه الحاله يطرح سؤال يعني
رئيس مجموعه يتحدث عن ان فتح او ان
السلاح على باخ متكامله يفتح الطريق الى
العمق الاوكراني ما دقه هذا
لا اعتقد ذلك حتى هذه اللحظه لانه المدن
الرئيسيه الثلاث التي تقع الى الغرب منها
سلافيان كراماتوريسك
وما بعدها تبعد مسافات ما بين عشرين كيلو
متر اربعين كيلو متر 55 كيلو متر تم بناء
ثلاثه قطوط دفاعيه يفترض انها فاعله
وعمليه الاستمرار في الاندفاع حتى المركز
الثقل الرئيسي اكراماتورسك لا اعتقد انه
لا يزال صعب على القوات الروسيه ان تتحدث
حول ذلك
شكرا جزيلا من عمان لواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري